Final Fantasy 7 remake that's a game I
played for hours of I may have been
trained I'm gonna tell you all about the
stuff that I saw in a recent preview
session so that chapter 1 chapter 2
chapter 7 and a bitter chapter 10 as
well so the opening has you run through
the Mako reactor with as cloud with you
mate Barret and the recipe a launch so
if you've been paying attention to all
the stuff that they've been releasing
about 5 to 7 remake you'll probably know
this bit become just run through the
industrial area I go to the Mako reactor
fight about to do this merit and
eventually get the Scorpion boss so what
was new to me here is the stuff that
comes directly afterwards which kind of
really shows off how much an expanded
scope this is now you probably already
know that this first release of remake
is only going to be setting like Midgar
which is basically 10% it's like the
final game and seeing all the
extrapolation that they did of like
scenes and like moments it really drives
home just how big this thing is probably
gonna be so I've been playing the
original in the lead-up to the release
of remake and knowing how the events
unfold it's crazy how much more there is
so like if you play a lot of narrative
games you'll be familiar with this slow
walk sequence we basically just slowly
meander through an environment you like
to take in the atmosphere and you like
listen to people talk there's a lot of
that so you get to actually have a lot
of time just looking at this brand new
city they've never seen you know you can
look up and you can see like the plate
which splits the poor from the rich
there's a lot of detail and the city
streets that all the civilians are like
you know I never really thought about
what the the civilians of Midgar would
be like they're just like ordinary
people and there are a few moments where
you dig into like clouds psyche if you
know clouds backstory you know he's got
some [ __ ] going on and you know that
this remake explores that a lot more in
these sort of quieter moments Final
Fantasy 7 was not a small game it's
certainly not an unambitious game but I
never thought about it like this before
you know I never thought about mid Yara
is like a real city and you know it's
got graffiti and you know ads and like
all the little bits
little details like restaurants and
shops and you know that's stuff that's
on you and it really makes it feel like
a brand new game in a lot of ways coming
back to the the flower-girl bit where
you know cloud runs into a flower girl
as he's escaping that scene just flew by
like a second and original because you
know he was this flower girl anyway
obviously you later to know that she's
Aerith and Aerith has become a beloved
character in the fandom and sort of that
flower girl scene is it's it's expanded
into like a ten-minute sequence where
you like bump into area if you have a
conversation with her all that's to say
is that there is a lot more to the story
here as well not just the exploration
and gameplay after that scene everything
cloud actually have a run-in with the
guards and that leads to and like a
chase sequence I guess it's more of a
chance for you to explore the city in a
sort of more nonlinear fashion it's
still pretty linear a bit you know there
are avenues and sort of side piles you
can take you'll be like climbing up
rooms and sort of getting into new areas
of the city finding like treasure chests
and like getting new material and like
gear for cloud and maybe this is
basically a chance for you to like get
to grips with the combat system a little
bit more and some more sort of involved
fights that sequence ended in sort of
like a mini boss fight before you jump
onto the train with this like named
enemy called the Huntsman and it taught
you to start thinking about positioning
and like strategies in combat as opposed
to just like whaling on a dude
[Music]
after Chapter two they jumped us into
Chapter seven it's the second mercury
after a sort of sabotage mission where
you've got Tifa in your team as well
who's great because he was my favorite
this sequence had you running through
the Microraptor again is that there's a
lot more to get through I guess they're
a lot more puzzles these that term
lightly because this was a section that
made me feel like okay no expanding
another's content but how much of that
is just gonna feel like filler there's a
Laser grid that goes on and off and
you'd have to like time your dashes to
get through them and there was a
sequence where you had to like find a
keycard that was located somewhere in
like a science room to to then use to
activate a computer so you could you
know ditch one of the Airbus's
components to make him weaker in the
upcoming battle and you could choose you
know whether to drop their like the
heavy attacks or you know reduce the
dexterity and stuff which is cool but
you had this basically happened like
three or four times which kind of made
me think like I hope there's not too
much of this because this is kind of
boring and I guess we'll only find out
in the full game
programming core plant for disposal
I was thinking the same thing this is
the first thing I say that anyone who
asks me about the game is like the
fighting is the best part of this game
obviously the original was a turn-based
system it was sort of active you know we
had the meetings and stuff but this one
is basically more or less all real-time
with some tactical pause elements to it
as well you hit square to do a regular
attack and the melee characters like
cloud and Tifa that basically goes one
to one with their strikes and for the
ranged characters you basically hold the
attack button to have sustained fires
like that his gun arm and arif has staff
which you thought you think it's a melee
weapon but she just shoots like magical
bolt flowers out of it I Carmen but it's
something like that she's a long-range
character basically and each character
has a secondary ability that's a
triangle which sort of defines how you
might play them so cloud as I mentioned
has the secondary stance which makes his
attacks a bit heavier but some kana bet
he can't dodge deep is one sort of acts
more as like a heavy attack it's
basically just looked like willing
uppercut that is sort of like a charged
shot of which there's a lot of damage
but it's a single shot and quite a lot
of cool down and Aerith has like sort of
a charged long-range magic attack but
you have to like hold it down and charge
it you can't do anything else and while
you're attacking you'll charge up your
ACB meter which said they've rigged
purpose is basically a special meter in
this one and once you've gotten a
segment of special meter you can then
use a spell or a ability and you do this
in two ways so one is you can assign up
to four abilities to shortcut buttons
basically r1 and a face button and that
lets you basically use these abilities
still in real time and just sort of work
it into your combos so you can just do
like slash slash braver the second way
to do it is through a tactical pause so
once you hit a button and it goes into
like a super slow down not completely
still but it's slow enough either like
peruse the menu at your own leisure and
sort of pick your ability like targeted
at a specific person summon creatures
which are a staple of farm fancy games
kind of work the same way as well when
you have the ability to summon a summon
creature like get rid of Shiva or
Leviathan which were the ones I saw you
basically call upon them and they come
up as an extra
you can't control them directly but you
can spend the ATB meter of any of your
party members to ask them to do a
specific ability and once their time
runs out they'll then do their big
flashy cinematic attack which you know
you've come to know and love when I
eventually did get back get to the
Airbus defied you know that's a fight
which is famous for splitting up your
party for the first time I think I have
to make sure I was switching to t4 and
Barrett making sure Barrett was like
getting his like he still skinned up so
we take less damage like Tito was like
out of the firing range because she's
really up close and sort of making sure
everyone's in their right place
it really did for more like a tournament
RPG or strategy game in that sense so I
think once we really do get to the late
game you know you won't be able to rely
on real time as much more you know you
can still do that then it'd be a lot
harder which I quite like I mean me
personally I didn't really want Final
Fantasy 7 to be like a full-on action
game you know you still want those RBG
elements and you know those are
definitely still there I should also
mention that the performance is actually
really good I was quite surprised by
that but the English boys cause I've
done a really good job I'm still a bit
hesitant
unlike Barrett's like des fiction like
he's just straight out Tropic Thunder
which is a little weird but he still has
some goofy lines which I quite like and
he had some good new ones that I heard
they jumped me up to chapter 10 after
that which was the absolute fight in the
sewers and this was just to show off
like a sort of made to like game boss
fight and I had Aerith with me as well
and so this was the first time I you
know I think anyone has got the scene
Aerith playing in combat I might be
wrong but I think so so it's basically
using her for the entire time which is
you know you'd expect all the characters
to be quite different but you know
Aerith is obviously a support character
and you know when I played Final Fantasy
originally or she did was like heal and
buff and stuff not so in remake it's
actually pretty involved everyone else
is obviously being controlled by the
computer and they're all in close so
they're getting creamed because you
can't control anyone at once so you have
to make sure it buffs her up you can
make sure the heels are okay so I guess
even if you are just playing as Erath
the real-time combat still feels really
exciting and like you know there's
always [ __ ] happening and all the time
so after playing three to four hours of
remake I mean it was already a game I
knew I was gonna play and you know
obviously like millions of people who
played the original I don't want to play
this anyway and there's like a really
good nostalgia factor there like when
the music kicked in with the a busted
battle I was like oh man this is so good
and like going back to playing the
original now I'm just like I can't wait
to see all of this in a new form so yes
that's a Fantasy 7 remake again that is
looking pretty good yeah who would have
thought huh they worked for so long on
making this damn thing and it's gonna
take a million years for us to see the
end but it actually looks pretty good
and I'm excited to play it
[Music]